anger and expressing anger did you know
people it can lead you to a happier life
medical daily composted a study at the
University of Jena
in Germany and it revealed that being
hot-tempered and expressing your anger
actually can add years to your life we
like to think oh if you're you know
somehow so evolved and just pleasant and
smiley all the time that is the key to
happiness but no it's not the case how
do you deal with your anger
there are so many places I could go with
this right now first I love that it's
the Germans Toria Sui know about placing
anger like doing this study and you know
I think they mentioned in this study
that it was the Italians and the
Spaniards live two years longer than
everyone else because their fiery people
and I was like where do the black people
fall were in there because I'm the fiery
of the fiery people but I guess we're
all being killed out by each other
really young so our you know life rate
goes down from the moment we're bored
see but you're saying this all with a
smile on your face right now so it's not
born out of this anger right I am an
angry person I don't think you could be
a thinking sentient person in this world
without being angry about something I
will say I will probably outlive
everyone at this table and it has
nothing to do with my race but I do
verbalize my anger at all times I feel
it is part of my my journey and how I
protect myself to tell somebody that
they have pissed me off from the guy at
Kinkos who's not moving quick enough to
get me my copies to the
woman standing in line that's too close
behind me to Dave Rubin who you've not
made me angry yet but I'm yeah where are
you going with this by the end of this
I'll have come up with some reason so
yeah maybe I will be the guy that lives
to be 150 because I will tell you you
know immediately you just pissed me off
and I'm gonna tell you why now what are
you going to do to make me feel better
Jackie what do you do is it comedy is
that how you get your also when I read
this article I it's like Free Willy it
wants to like run be pretty yeah I
called my father that I haven't talked
to in 20 years and just like let him
have it when I read the article so I
feel like you know I'm like 10 years
younger today yeah exactly
Dave what about for you is a comedy
telling people jokes if you get the
angst out and then oh I turn it inward
I'm Irish Catholic so I'm I will be
lucky to survive through this broadcast
it's yeah that's what we do we are we
kind of we push it down stuff it down
and then we have heart attacks women you
know 43 it's what we do I'm thinking oh
I I do I see a shrink now and I try to
you know I I talk about things and I and
I try to express anger it still it feels
very strange very strange oh sure
there's good for article a little
racially polarizing in the ran way when
they were talking the through you the
angry black man like we're but I mean
and you know what ad in the angry black
gay man and it really becomes something
different
but I found it a little something when
they were talking about the Spaniards
and the Italians and like they broke it
down racially and it was this like sort
of the calm serenus of the British and I
was like calm and serene this of the
Brits I mean what are you trying to say
like I believe they've been involved in
a couple of wars you know I think it I
don't know have we gotten to the point
now where we're actually like looking
breaking down things racially and we're
saying like these people were calmer and
these because that stereotypes and that
only leads to
you know anger hey just just calm down
just calm down well what do you think I
just moved here to California where
everyone is smiling at me saying hello I
walked my dog down the street and people
are I'm starting to say hello to people
which is very uncomfortable for a New
York comedian giving a car goes onto the
road yeah the horn I've been pretty
controlled so far but what do you what
do you make of all these smiley happy
people here are they just sublimating it
or is this real here don't whether life
it's illegal weed you know you're there
alone there are a lot of reasons I mean
it's just it's a good life what's not to
smile about the mountains you turn you
look there mountains everywhere you look
you know you're 20 minutes away from the
ocean trees